[Music]
so john you and i were actually talking
earlier this morning in a meeting and um
discussing things around your book new
book coming out
um that with
all the wackiness happening in the world
that
uh i mean your book and some of the
materials that you're putting out are
all about
dealing with your past um you know own
your past change your futures the title
the new book but this idea that that you
know things that have happened to me as
an individual or to you guys out there
as an individual the trauma that you
experienced
during covid or the trauma experience
from family or the trauma you
experienced from a job or whatever
trauma wherever it was
that's kind of like one set of
anxiety-inducing things you call them
bricks in the backpack right
and then there's a whole other set of
anxiety-inducing things and both of
these affect money they affect job they
affect marriage because it affects
mental health basically uh but the
anxiety-inducing trauma type things are
um i mean stuff like russia and ukraine
uh stuff like
out-of-control inflation used cars are
going up
all right which makes me think i'm in a
cartoon or something i mean instead of
real life and this must be a pixar movie
i mean how to use cars go up it's
impossible and uh you know uh supply
chain stuff is just bizarre uh just
trying to get something purchased and
get it shipped to you
is crazy so people are experiencing
i guess environmental type things that
are impacting us the new negative news
we'll just call it and then you've got
things that are individual to you in
your life that makes sense absolutely
two different buckets how do you deal
with those different buckets you know i
was
on an interview yesterday and talking
about this exact thing and
what i told the the guy was man
i woke i tell people for a living to get
off your devices that's that's one of my
cornerstone messages get off your
devices and be with real people
and i found myself yesterday i got up at
5am to go exercise and do my morning
routine like i always do and the first
thing i did was pulled out my phone to
see if putin had invaded
and instead of looking at it and seeing
there's tension and closing it and going
about my day i sat there and sat there
went to this new site and this new site
this new site so alice went down the
rabbit hole yes and i missed my workout
i missed everything i grabbed coffee and
i was able to high-five my kids and head
out the door
instead of
here's the thing you know i can control
about what putin's doing zero nothing
there's not a thing i can do about that
but no one else can either by the way
what i what i could do was i could have
got my exercise in i could have made my
wife's coffee and brought it to her
because i know that little tiny acts of
service when i'm stressed out helps calm
me down i could have written a note to
my kids and said hey i got an early
morning of media hits i love you guys i
miss you i could have done some things
that i know
bring me peace and bring my anxiety
level down instead of fed it and so what
i what i tell everybody to do is look at
the things in your life you can control
and lean in on those and literally use
the off button on some of these things
you can check on russia once or twice a
day and that's it nothing else is going
to change
and if it does there's nothing you could
do about it right or the inflation or
the get your house unless you're on the
joint chiefs of staff you don't need to
be riding it all day long you can't ride
it all day long and here's the thing
because it'll ride you it will
bury you it will bury you my heart rate
is up as though america is getting
shelled right now and we're not right
we're not and so man take care of the
people in your area take care of you and
i'm not saying stick your head in the
sand and avoid it no this is a worldwide
issue we all need to be on
in the know on this but get in the know
and then get back out don't go swimming
and bathing in the cesspool
right get what you need and then get out
of there man and then deal with your
people in your life yeah the the problem
is
inputs matter
and i mean and if you're incredible if
all you do is fee and that includes who
you hang around with it includes what
you read it includes your screen which
you watch yeah it includes if you're
doing social media or you're not doing
social media it includes podcasts you
get off work and you listen to you
listen to a murder podcast on the way
home just you can get to law order svu
right yeah for dinner like you're just
feeding yourself this stuff yeah inputs
matter because if you put if all your
inputs are crap your brain's crap your
brain is terrified all day fight or
flight all day all day and then a real
thing shows up like inflation like you
go to the grocery store and you look at
your budget and say
oh i got to make some choices on meat or
vegetables this month that's a real
thing that you need you need space and
capacity in your mind and body to be
able to handle those issues that is
taken up by other fake
drama right it's just going to go and go
and go and it going
so you do really need to identify
causes of stress and put them in one of
two buckets things i can do something
about things i can't that's right things
i can't you need to limit the inputs
absolutely all day every day just just
just stop i had a friend's watching cnn
watching fox all day long i think we're
i think he's in a rubber room now yeah i
mean if that's your only input is a
24-hour news cycle all day long
100 of it is hyped yep exaggerated and
bad yes that's exactly i mean it's just
like you know eat i i'm gonna eat
chocolate bars all day long 24 7
and then think that's going to work out
from a nutrition standpoint i mean you
know or whatever negative thing you can
come up with to eat but i mean that
would gag you if you got past four of
them you know but uh it just
your mind is gagging that's right and
it's it's important to know
you we all should be a little bit
heightened right now we should all be
anxious right now this is a big deal
right and i'm i'm i'm anxious to see
what my government's going to do to
participate or not participate and what
my leadership's going to look like all
that's true and real and good prices are
real the gas i can't even like i have to
double take when you drive by a gas
station right all this stuff's real
and then what can i do about that i
can't fix the gas prices today and so
i'm gonna see it and i'm gonna go man
that's that's that stinks i'm gonna have
to make some adjustments in my budget
with my wife and then i'm gonna go about
my day because doubling down on that man
it's gonna make me a ball of rage that's
going to affect my kids my wife my
family my neighborhood and my work you
got to control the controllables and set
the rest of them and control the things
that aren't controllable that's right
that's right that's why they're not
called controllable i mean this is not
hard
and yet we have gotten into this between
social media 24-hour news cycle
um
i mean it used to be
you know walter cronkite for 30 minutes
in the evening your local news for 30
minutes in the evening and you had a
newspaper some of you don't know what
that is you could look it up on the
internet but
um and that was you know you were stuck
with that yeah and a lot of that was
hours and hours and hours behind but
then you had to go sit down with real
humans and you got to have dinner you
got the pontification circles well i
think this well i think this you're
engaging with real people and a real
human would say i think that's dumb i
think this and i think that and you had
real interactions and your body actually
goes
okay we're safe i got a real person
right here i got a real person right
here we're exchanging ideas and now it's
just grenade grenade grenade grenade
digital grenade that's right yeah that's
right which are about as bad as digital
courage yeah wow
scary times man scary times but you have
to control the situation you have to
control your environment it's uh you're
not going to get out of this otherwise